we simulated number one overall pick
Victor with Miami's rookie season with
the San Antonio Spurs in 2K and this is
how you performed Wendy was dominant
dropping buckets on whoever was in his
way crashing boards and blocking shots
he exceeded the expectations Scouts had
for him entering the draft Wendy won
Rookie of the Year and it wasn't close
averaging 26.9 points per game 9.5
rebounds per game and 2.8 blocks he
looked generational but the Spurs didn't
see much success only going 32-50 on the
season but they have every reason to
have faith towards the future led by
wemby watch out because evicted women
Yama era in San Antonio has officially
begun